hello everyone
um I'm David apgarian I work as Senior
Day scientist at disco and I am going to
present recommender
systems in market research shortly about
disco the company was founded in U.S in
2015. it has it attracted more than 100
million dollars of investment more than
3 million surveys are completed monthly
on our platform and we are collecting
more than one billion digital transpoons
monthly too and
um
uh the platform on which we are
completing those servers is called
survey janky it is a place where users
or members register they complete
surveys they earn rewards and then
afterwards this rewards are converted
into money and they are paid and we have
the second site where the companies that
want information or do want to do market
research they provide the service
and now talking about the problem that
we are trying uh to solve so we have
opinion sharing platform which is survey
gently this is the main Revenue
generating engine of the company so it's
important to do optimize that as much as
possible growth marketing dollars are
spent on user acquisition and naturally
the churn rate of the users in this
industry is very high so it's very
important to create the best experience
for the users to have a lower churn rate
so our problem here is to match users
with surveys because not all users can
complete all surveys and
um
so as I have mentioned most of our
surveys are first part coming from
third-party providers and the
complicating factor of that is that
whenever we show the service on our
platform the users click on the survey
but to and to complete the survey they
are redirected to the website of the
provider where they complete the survey
and it means that we do not see the
questions in the survey and we do not
see what are what answers this user is
giving so only whenever they go and
complete the survey there we get a
response this user completed this survey
this user disk is is disqualified or
when caught a full and some other
statuses there are dozens of them that's
not important and in our case we have a
lot of terminations and quota Foods in
the industry and I will say what means
determination let's say you enter the we
are initially we are doing rule-based
matching let's say there is a survey
project for which we have we need to
have 1000 completions they tell that we
want
um women aged 1824 uh 100 completions
main 100 then the other age groups and
gender groups and based on that we are
matching our users and service so
rule-based one and but it's very high
level like gender age and maybe
geographical region but not specific
questions and when they enter the survey
maybe
they will ask let's say did you watch
Queen's gambits if you say no maybe they
will say you are disqualified because we
are interested in people that watch this
movie or do you have this disease
because this is a drug company and they
want to do some exploration that's why
they're asking these questions and then
disqualify you and you need to try
another survey because you didn't manage
to this survey and we can know as I have
mentioned as we do not see the questions
and answers we cannot do that beforehand
and the other problem is this quote of
rule as I have mentions for each let's
say we want users aged 1824 women and
let's say we reach 99 completion and one
completion is remaining we send this
survey to many people as you know it is
real time maybe 10 people started
completing this survey one of them will
be quick and will complete successfully
the others that even though they
completed the survey successfully we'll
take that already quota is full you are
not going to get paid nothing maybe you
spend 15 minutes or 20 minutes so you
can imagine how annoying is that and we
try to load
that rate and also I want to mention
that it's not only us completing that
survey so at the same time we are
competing with other companies like
disco who have users that are completing
surveys so there is competition between
the companies to complete that provider
surveys so we have a problem we do not
see questions we do not see answers and
we cannot solve that no one is going to
share that information with us but uh
there is a workaround and um quite
interesting one so we can do
personalized survey matching how does
that work the logic is this let's say we
have Anna Anna completed survey 1 survey
two and Survey free and we have John
that completed survey one so it means in
this case it's one survey but it in
reality it can be 100 common surveys it
means that online John we do not know
how but they are similar and it means
that if there is a survey that Anna
completed successfully in this case
survey Tunes survey free we can
recommend to John so as they are
completing they are like completing
successfully similar surveys for some
reason we do not know underlying uh
factors that they are similar but we
know that the probability that John will
become complete this service is high and
let's say we have knowledge that
completed only survey 4 we cannot give
any recommendation because there are no
similarities and we have survey 1 survey
two and our main completed survey one
survey two we will take survey three and
recommend to Armand so this is very
simple logic we do not do it manually or
rule based one the data science approach
of solving this problem is recommender
system and we will talk about what
recommenders is like what type of
recommenders systems there are
and there are personalized and
non-personalized non-personalized one
for example popularity based model is
non-personic personalized one it's very
easy let's say we have Amazon and Amazon
wants to make recommendations they can
just get the most popular item that is
being sold a lot to everyone or music
recommender system you this song is very
popular if majority of the people are
listening you can you can recommend to
other people as well because most of
them uh like it but you know that it
will not it is not a perfect solution
the better solution is personalized one
in case of first night's recommender
systems we have content based
collaborative filtering these are two
approaches and the hybrid is the
combination of the two so content based
approach is when as I said we have John
and Anna when they register on our
website they
uh give us their profile information
actually they are answering 16 mandatory
questions including age gender uh are
you like medical status education and
based on that you can basically just
cosine similarity calculate that
similarity between the users and give
recommendations my colleague is working
on this and this is uh this is uh
performance is not that good as if
compared to collaborative filtering but
it has one advantage first let me
present collaborative filtering in case
of collaborative filtering you are
calculating the similarity based on the
way of the users best based on their
historical activities so in my case I
presented like how the surveys that they
completed what was successful and what
was unsuccessful so no profile
comparison no feature comparison only
historical activities in case of
e-commerce website it can be the user
clicked or like liked or the song it can
be like the song or didn't like the song
so in case of collaborative filtering we
use only historical data but there is a
very common problem it's called start
problem it's when let's say we have a
new user we do not have any historical
data on this user so we cannot make
recommendations or if we have one or two
completion or attempts we call it
attempt it's this data is not enough to
give like a good probability like
generate good probability of I wouldn't
recommend that survey so that is called
cold start problem and in that case
content based approach works better
because you say that as these two users
profile are similar the likelihood that
these users will complete similar survey
is very high and also I want to mention
another important thing it's not only
the users are similar and they will like
if they complete it successfully 50
service they have 50 service in common
successfully completed then we can
recommend good surveys like the survey
that one completed and the other one
didn't complete it
we can recommend that to that person but
we can also unrecommend surveys so if I
went quote a full on this survey we do
not we will not give the same survey to
the person that is similar to you so if
we see that all you have a lot of common
quota fools it means that you are
similar in Quota Foods as well so it is
negative things but you are seeing like
similar and when we see that the
probability to go quota full is high we
will just not recommend that survey
because like you
may get a quota food so in case of
collaborative filtering so this is the
approach and implementation of
collaborative filtering can be with
memory based models and it can be Memory
based and model based memory in case of
memory base it's for example K nearest
neighbor in this case you do this
similarity calculation in real time but
the problem there is that if your user
the number of users and number of
servers grow it's very hard to do that
calculations like you will have latency
issue in case of model based approach
you do the calculations like you train a
model beforehand and then whenever the
users come come you make a prediction
that you need to make sure that your
model has the user ID and Survey ID so
the users and service should be in the
model so it means that if you want your
model to be comparable to this memory
based approach you need to retrain your
model very frequently for example in our
case our model is retrained every two
minutes
in order to have the new users new
activities of existing users so or even
use even new surveys so it's very
important to update the model as fast as
possible so in case of model based
approach the popular one is Matrix
factorization and there is
implementation like of Matrix
factorization with which is called
factorization machines and it's more
advanced than other Matrix
characterization apologies like
STD singular value decomposition for
example or there is SVD plus plus so
factorization machines we will talk
about that
factorization the seminal paper or
factorization machine involves uh
published in 2010 by Stefan Randall and
the advantage of this model is that it
is can be trained in linear time it is
linear time estimation compared to
Matrix factorization in in which case
you have NM let's say n is your users
and M is your service so you always have
NM parameters to learn which is not
compared to this one is not linear so
and this one is also handles Parts data
for example in in our case the data is
passed because not all users are trying
all the surveys or uh not again and here
is the formula of that like the
estimation the loss like the function
that we are optimizing the parameters
that we are learning so the number of
parameters here is is p which is this
part the linear part and in here we have
interaction term so interaction
interaction term shows like we are
learning parameter between a user this
user completing this survey for all of
that the model is learning
parameters and as you can see in this
case it's not just one coefficient it is
a vector and indeed that Vector this
parameter K which you can change when
you are training model you can give you
can say I want a model that has only two
elements I want a model that has six
elements so if the complexity
is higher then you will increase the
number of this K but this is hyper
parameter that you can tune so and with
this model not only you can solve like a
recommender system related tests but you
can even do
um regression like logistic regression
like binary classification and
regression tasks and there is a very
good implementation of factorization
machines the library of the package is
called xlearn underneath it is working
with C plus plus so it's very super fast
it's high performance it's quite easy to
use actually the data structure is very
specific it uses SPM I do not know
whether you are familiar if you are fine
with the data processing like to give
the data in a shape that it requires
then it's it will be very super fast it
has out of car learning so it's not like
if the size of the your data is very big
and you cannot give it at once you can
do it in like by batches and it also has
online learning you do not need to
retrain the model uh all the time you
just can give them
the initial data so here you can see the
comparison on single MacBook Pro with
lib FM FFM and leap FM and lib linear so
the performance how execution time how
fast is that and in case of
factorization machines there is also
field aware of factorization machines so
fieldwear factorization machines means
that for example I was talking users age
gender or for survey we have parameters
called like payout duration of the
survey and the conversion of the survey
so these parameters you also can give as
an input to your model at the moment
that we do like we do not use that but
you can give other parameters to the
model and
yeah before passing to the next time I
like to the next slide I want to mention
that this is used for uh CTR click
through rate prediction and this model
was used to win multiple
um multiple Kegel competitions actually
this is 2010 model
now there are more advanced model even
you can have this bad model or
transformation Transformer models and
other models to solve that problem but
in our case from the business point of
view we do not want to have the most
advanced one we want to have something
that works in production and then later
you can optimize that so it's not a
Kegel competition in the business they
want predictability and stability and
here with these things at least so far
we have seen that
so how the model training happens it it
may sound surprising but we just give
this user
attempted this survey was it successful
or no this is the only data that we give
as an input to this model to be trained
at the end uh whenever you the new
survey comes or you want to see to to
not new survey but if this user didn't
complete this given survey we just give
as an input user ID survey ID and it
will give you a probability it can give
0 1 but it can give like in case of
binary classification actually at the
end this is binary classification tasks
so this factorization machine at the end
you are turning a training model like
you would train a logistic regression
model uh actually binary classification
let's put it that way so here we are
taking last one month data and then we
try we are training the model and and
then we take next Monday's data and we
are assuming like in next Monday we have
this user attempted this survey and
um so the the model does not know about
this data and we are calculating the
probability whether this like what is
the probability that this user will
complete this survey and we have the
actual value and based on that we are
doing sorting of survey for one user
let's say one user can have 100 let's
say 100 survey or in this case we do 12
recommendations and we are comparing
Precision at K how many of the
predictions were correct and we were
increasing the conversion rate the
conversion rate shows out of 100
attempts how many will be successful we
have seen that we are we increased the
conversion rate a lot so talking about
the engineering part uh like our
infrastructure structure is we are on
AWS Cloud here you can see
we have Amazon redshift this is our
database the historical data is there so
through like the model the code is
running on Amazon sagemaker the like
it's Jupiter notebook querying this data
um and training it so we use Amazon
Cloud watch for scheduling the model as
I like to actually this model now is not
scheduled because we do not even turn
the instance so as I have mentioned it
is retraining every two minutes so when
one training happens uh the next one
after that starts the next one so this
instance is not turned off but we have
some models for which we use Amazon
Cloud watch so we say the models like
you need to start this instance every
day at 1 pm and that is done by
cloudwatch and the the we use Lambda
function to start the instance so we use
this Amazon API get a Gateway so if
something happens with this error here
we have trike set if something happens
we want to restart the model so it
closes itself but before that it sends a
request to Amazon API Gateway which
comes and restarts this Lambda which
comes and turns on this instance again
so that's not that important that model
saved is on S3 S3 is a storage some of
you are familiar it's like the disk of
your computer so this is the training
process and from the end point like we
have the fast API endpoint and it reads
the model and data from here actually I
use slack for reporting for example if
something happens with the endpoint I
will get
reports on my slack that's not the best
way to do this for example there is
opportunity and other approaches but
it's very convenient at least for me so
the user when user enters survey janky
it makes there are some other things
happening but that our endpoint gets the
service that are matched for this user
then we take this service and we just
rank them based on the probability so
here this part actually change we here
have eks cluster on AWS and we have cicd
pipeline so our code is on gitlab when
we push changes to the gitlab that will
trigger build and deploy and this ecase
cluster will be updated in real time so
we do not turn off the end point or
switch off it it will there are 32
instances so it updates each instance
the code for its instance sequentially
so
talking about the performance one
request is have like handled the
prediction happens in less than 70
milliseconds and for example during last
week we handled
140 million requests and without major
problems
so
this part is old so this is the first
API code I think nothing is seen here
but this is the structure like they are
making post requests with to us we are
getting the service processing and
giving a response and we have also
background tasks for example background
task goes and brings let's say real-time
conversion and duration of that survey
on our system if someone would be
interested I am happy to share what we
have there and also I want to mention as
I have mentioned stability is important
for example one of the issues that we
encountered is memory leakage sometimes
in your code for example we were using
hyper GBM model not for this one but we
were using hyper GBM model for
predictions and it can happen that you
know that the Python's memory management
is not the best it handles automatically
but it's not the best so maybe after
handling several request 100 or 200 by
the time your memory will be filled in
and your endpoint will crash so that
happened in case of xlearn as well for
example instead of using its python API
we switched to
its shell version then this problem
solved itself instead of python we you
used a shell version so I think there
are there are some other problems that
we encountered but that's not like if I
can answer the questions related to that
so talking about impact so we are
increasing the conversion it means that
we are increasing both user satisfaction
and the revenue of the company and
actually during last month as I have
mentioned we are competing with other
companies as well there is a big
Marketplace it's called Lucid actually
it is the biggest company in market
research and on their platform we became
number one one by earnings per click
after implementing our model that we
have and it means that our users now
like are making 20 to 40 percent less
clicks that are completing more surveys
and earning more Revenue so we are like
they do not need to try many times to
get the survey on which they will
convert
um I think that's it thank you
okay time for questions
um thank you for your presentation it
was very great
um I have three short questions first of
them did you try it uh LS alternating
list squares for Matrix factorization
um
what how it compared to to your method
uh another question and did you try it
you said you use as a offline metric for
your model uh as Precision at Key due to
try it in dcg or something similar and
how do you evaluate your model
performance in production do you have
some a b testing
decision thank you thank you but the
first question was so let me come from
the end and you will repeat the question
okay so sorry so about talking about
testing so whenever I say this Precision
K metric in reality you train your model
actually the score for uh for evaluating
the model this factorization Machine
model I am using rocioc score so because
our data imbalanced so with Roca you see
score we are choosing the best model and
as I have mentioned we are using this
one day's data to do the available
education but that is not correct as
well because in reality we need to as I
have mentioned you need to retrain the
model every two minutes because you need
to take into account all the new
attempts of that user and Survey so that
evaluation even that one okay we see
everything is good but in reality there
are many factors that can affect the
performance so the best way to see your
model's performance in real time in our
case all our users are segmented into 10
groups we started running like 90 is the
control and ten percent is our model
when we see that it is performing well
we have it's not only one metrics but
okay I cannot show it now but we have 10
metrics so so we have the number of
completers earnings per minute earnings
per click
the revenue as a like the absolute
number per user we have conversion rate
quota full rate so we are considering
many many factors comparing test with
control and we make sure that we run it
quite long because in short term you
will not see so at the moment whatever
we like 90 is running on our model and
even I would say 100 the other 10 is the
new model that we are testing so we
started with just 10 now it's running on
90 and it is making the impact
that everyone wants okay okay another
question is ALS uh alternating least
squares actually I heard about that
model I do not remember whether we tried
or not but if we are talking about the
models that we tried one is for example
one popular one is
um
SVD plus plus singular value
decomposition if I am not mistaken it
was showing similar results but as I
have mentioned this model is first of
all Matrix factorization is uh like the
complexities in linear time and the
biggest Advantage I would say is this
excellent package because in the other
cases you need to implement it from
scratch but it is done in C plus plus
underneath it's very efficient
like it was done by Chinese team so they
did very good job so that's why we are
using that so the speed is very
important for us we need to make sure
that like with the old one all the model
that they have the latency was like
around five milliseconds the computation
because it was like in simple formula
with this approach initially our request
like we were predicting in one request
prediction was happening in one and five
seconds then we see like we wanted to do
pre-computing like calculate all the
probabilities but I didn't beforehand
and then when user comes we give it to
them but the problem with that is we
have let's say uh 500
000 users and a lot of surveys I
remember we needed to calculate 5
billion peers every 30 seconds the
calculation we're doing with parallel
processing but the problem was to
separate and give to that user so
because it didn't work with like I
changed my whole code of requests like
handling the request and from one five
seconds it became 70 milliseconds okay
thank you you're welcome
foreign
thank you for presentation I have a
question like for new users like knowing
information how do you solve inference
problem for new users yeah actually
whatever I present is it's just the
people of Iceberg so whenever you we get
these probability this user completing
this survey it is personalized
conversion rate this user completing
this survey we also have survey
conversion rate so whenever a provider
is giving us a survey it okay it says
that I want this many surveys to be
completed but also it says three main
parameters one is payout how much they
are going to pay us for one completion
one provided for one project they may
pay like on every G3 I'm not mistaken
it's 1.8 dollars for one completion the
second parameter is duration let's say
they say they have the survey on average
will take 15 minutes and the other thing
is conversion rate so they will tell
that the conversion of this survey is a
50. so it means that out of 100 attempts
on average they will say that 50 like 50
completions would be successful so
whenever we take these parameters and
whenever the new user is the user is new
we already have these parameters and
based on uh all the all the projects
that we have on our platform we know
this Service Pro performance for example
we know that this survey is high
conversion survey then we are going to
give this recommendation to that user so
okay we are not sure that this user is
will complete it this survey but service
differs
by their conversion rate let's say if
they want someone that has PhD its
conversion rate is different than the
person that they want let's say to know
how they are going to vote in upcoming
elections so we have the levers there
and for new users we are concentrating
more on conversion and for existing
users that are experience we convert
convert on payout so continuing that we
have approach called multi-criteria
optimization so this payout duration
conversion and also
personalized conversion which is get we
get by this factorization machine are
combined together by coefficients So
based on historical data we learn
coefficients for these parameters to
maximize the revenue if we want you can
maximize other parameters as well we say
both coefficients we need to have
like how to combine these numbers
together to get a score but by sorting
which we will maximize our Revenue so
why this you need to equilibrium so you
can recommend the highest payout service
to the user but as the conversion rate
of these high payout service is very
high you are not going to get enough
completions and your overall Revenue
will be less but you can recommend them
a lot of high conversion surveys but
their payment will be low and at the end
you will not again maximize your Revenue
it's like
producing expensive cards like
Lamborghini and selling 100 of them and
producing must have mass production cars
where you sell each by let's say ten
thousand dollars and you should not
necessarily you should not necessarily
think that that expensive cars are
making more for example Lamborghini if
I'm not mistaken at the end was bought
by Volkswagen or mass
mass card producer I do not remember so
our goal with this multi-criteria
optimization is to maximize the revenue
balancing the payout conversion and
duration and uh yeah okay thank you and
I have another question like related to
this information you said like do you
use this information to
to learn content-based system as I
understand you are using collaborative
filtering yes methods like factorization
machines but you you have another
attribute data so you can use also like
content based system do you do that yeah
as I have mentioned my colleague is
working on that we have XG boost based
model it's just you can say binary
classification where we give as an input
user profile data and Survey data this
payout duration conversion and based on
that the model predicts whether this
user is going to complete this survey so
how it works historically it like it
learns based on historical data that the
user with this type of profile completed
this survey and didn't complete the
other one based on and also you have
these survey parameters based on that
it's generating probability between 0
and 100 and we are doing ranking okay
thank you thank you Tom
another question
thank you very much for the great
presentation and just small question
about the new users so I guess when they
are interested in your into your
platform they give you some demographic
information right and do you use them to
do it like basic recommendation do you
do you have any initial models which use
just demography information without
yeah historical data and to give them
some recommendation based on that so as
I have mentioned before even when there
were no data science models when let's
say you are a user you enter the website
you are a new user we need to go and
match surveys like what's defined let's
say we have inventory of 5000 surveys we
need how many of them match you there is
a rule-based approach for example you
are age 20 uh your age is 23 you are men
and you are located in some U.S state
they when they give the IELTS that data
we do rule-based matching so this is 100
but
afterwards no matching is happening so
as I have mentioned we have this my
colleague is working on this
content-based one and this is uh it is
getting all these demographic data
whether you are married or know what car
you have whether you have children
educational level all these staff are
getting as an input to that model and
they are making prediction but as I have
mentioned
like this is not as precise as this
historical
database one but in the case of new
users that approach is better
they get great and another small
question about the model performance so
you train your model every two minutes
and your commercial rate you said
increasing over time
so can you give us like
General
change of the performance during the
last one year or last two months how
fast your conversion rate is increasing
actually we when we as I have mentioned
it's important to increase the
conversion but it's not our goal so our
goal is to maximize Revenue so even even
if we can increase conversion we are not
going like we care about that but it uh
if we can increase Revenue more and keep
the conversion as it is it's even that
is good for us it's so in all the model
that we have in production when I said
we earnings by click we became one in
that case we were increasing the
conversion uh by 20 for all the users
that I want to mention
um other things this is something
internal but in our case we have
different Integrations and because of
the way that like we are startup we grow
very fast we are not able to affect 100
of the users when I say 100 users I mean
100 of the users that we can affect the
other part still we cannot affect but in
upcoming months it will be so it is
infrastructure change so the ones that
we impact directly the conversion
increases by 40 even but you should uh
40 in percentage terms in absolute term
this is internal information I cannot
tell you what is our conversion but you
can assume that it's not high as I have
mentioned in the beginning that the
churn rate is very high and the
conversion is very high when I joined
first disco and I tried the product
myself I said how can happen that people
are making money with this because you
need to
attend hundreds of surveys to be able to
complete let's say 10 20 service
successfully so it's not that easy and
we are trying to improve the user's
experience yeah thanks thanks
no other questions
thank you for your presentation I have
just a technical question so in from the
point of view statistics
uh we aren't getting randomized samples
they are chosen uh What uh is this
correct or not from the point of view
statistic statistics of randomized
Trials you mean are we talking about a b
testing no uh when we are like when we
need to take a survey it should be
randomized to include all the
populations on where we are choosing
from the population different people so
the conversion rate should would be
higher then our sample of people isn't
truly randomized is is is this correct
from the standpoint of statistical
inference so yeah theory in business are
totally different things and I wouldn't
say that whatever we have is
statistically correct uh I hope it's not
pricing you should for example it is not
the only problem it is much smaller
problem than for example the fraud many
people can come register create 100
profile and tell that like and use this
100 profile to earn points and just
redeem so we have bigger problem but the
purpose here is like whenever provider
comes and wants to make a decision based
on that they not only think about the
accuracy have something that is
representative let's say the population
of United States everyone wants that but
that is very costly I think prep
practically impossible so your goal is
to have good enough data based on which
you can make decisions and it's also
about about the speed if you can tell me
that you will have statistically correct
uh like surveys completed in six months
my business cannot wait that much time
if you can tell me that you can have
give me results five percent less
accurate that in within one day I will
be happy to use that so for example
again when I joined disco I thought who
how they can do survey completing
service online who who is the person at
like in front of computer how can be
sure that the quality of data is good
but we have what we have this is a 17
billion dollar industry and people want
to make decision
um like having some data or some
impression how people think compared to
having no data is much better so we just
make sure that it's as accurate as
possible but as I have mentioned that is
not the most important factor here
so regarding that I want to add
something that is important too so if of
course we have time so not only we have
we are gathering opinion data we also
gather Behavior data so if someone asks
you how many times you are doing like
making purchases from let's say Amazon
you you may say two may say free but
this is changing you may be not
remembering so and your opinion may
change your behavior and opinion are in
reality different you will agree with
that yes so whenever you express your
opinion it's not necessarily mean that
you are going to act like like that so
one when I say We Gather this one
billion digital touch points we have a
extension you install it on your
computer we pay you for that you we get
uh like your consent together all your
actions on e-commerce websites and we
what you search what actions did you add
something to basket or something like no
other websites only e-commerce and when
you do that do that we have we are not
only tracking your actions but also we
send you surveys to complete that and we
compare the results and we have very hot
product now it's called ad measurement
and we have very big clients for example
one was Oscar ceremony so let's say they
are they want to make an advertisement a
video or something like that okay
we are out of time so everyone can go
but let me finish that so uh talking
about Oscar ceremony so before spending
let's say 10 million dollars or 50
million dollars on ads they are paying
us less amount of money and to do
testing one group of users are seeing
the advertisement and the other group is
not seeing and as we are tracking their
actions we still see whether the the
people that see the ads are affected or
no and based on that then they decide
whether the lift is enough and they
should spend this 50 million dollar on
the advertisement
[Applause]